[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 162 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform podcast.
I'm Mark Mandel, and I'm
very excited to be joined
yet again by Gabi Ferrara.
How are you doing today, Gabi?
GABI FERRARA: I am very good.
Thank you, Mark, for asking.
How are you?
MARK MANDEL: I'm doing OK.
Good to be joined by you
yet again on the podcast.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah,
I love being here.
It's nice.
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHS]
That's great.
So today, we are going to be
talking to Mohamed El-Geish,
talking about Voicea and
voice applications, which
I'm pretty excited by.
GABI FERRARA: Yes,
he will show us
the different ways how
they are approaching
ML to solve their problems.
That's going to be fun.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's really awesome.
And then afterwards, we
have a Question of the Week
that I think you're
going to ask me.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah.
So, Mark, what if I'm
working the terminal
in Cloud Shell and I want
to move to another computer?
How can I continue my work?
MARK MANDEL: That's
a great question.
So we'll answer that later.
[LAUGHTER]
GABI FERRARA: OK.
MARK MANDEL: So why don't we
get stuck into that Cool Things
of the Week?
I think you had
something right up first.
GABI FERRARA: So we
announced this week,
you will be able to
query inside BigQuery
without having a credit card.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice.
GABI FERRARA: So that means
that people like students
and other types of
organizations can
learn how to use BigQuery
without having to provide
financial information.
And it provides up to 1 terabyte
a month of querying capacity,
which is a lot for a free tier.
So that's exciting for me.
MARK MANDEL: That's
very, very cool.
Awesome.
And my Cool Thing of the Week--
there's a great article
talking about exploring
container security,
encrypting Kubernetes secrets
with Cloud KMS.
This is actually
really, really cool.
So if you used
Kubernetes, Kubernetes
has a thing called Secrets,
where you can store data in it,
especially things like
passwords and whatnot.
But by default, the
Kubernetes Secrets
are stored in plain
text, which if you
want to put really secret
stuff in there, is not ideal.
But there is a new
thing in GKE, which
is application-layer
secret encryption, that
is in beta right now, that
you can take advantage of.
It's pretty
straightforward to set up.
All you really need to
do is specify the key
that you want to
use inside Cloud KMS
to manage your secrets, and
pretty much you're good to go.
If you have a look
at the article,
it shows you a little Getting
Started Guide, as well
as links to some documentation
to get you going.
GABI FERRARA: Cool.
Also this week,
using data analytics,
the Golden State
Warriors announced
they're going to be
improving their fan
experience by using App
Engine and Firebase together
[INAUDIBLE].
So you have the blog
post there explaining
how it's going to be done.
And I have to confess,
Mark, I did not
know what Golden
State Warriors were.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: Admittedly,
we had to look it up.
We had to go online.
We're like, oh, it's
basketball in Oakland,
close to where I live.
GABI FERRARA: I thought it
was baseball for some reason.
MARK MANDEL: I feel like
that's something I should know.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah,
I'm sorry, people.
MARK MANDEL: That's all right.
There's a really great
article by our VP
of engineering,
Melody Meckfessell,
who we are huge fans of.
And you can actually listen
to her more in episode number
158 from the podcast as well.
Melody works very
deeply in DevOps land.
And she wrote an article
talking about a recent survey,
sponsored by Google Cloud,
by Harvard Business Review
analytics services,
talking about DevOps
and basically the
road to DevOps.
And in the blog post, they
outline seven steps for DevOps,
as well as a link to the
survey for more information.
But in there, there is
piloting a small project,
being an open-source
player, embedding security
within a software
development process,
apply DevOps best practices,
provide immersive training,
establish a no-blame culture,
build a culture that supports
DevOps, et cetera, et cetera.
So check out the blog
post for all the details,
as well as links to
the survey as well.
GABI FERRARA: And to finish
our list, "The Telegraph,"
in the UK, announced a
partnership with Google Cloud
to help them to
manage their media.
They're going to be using cool
things like AutoML classified
content.
So imagine all of those contents
that they have from way,
way back, being able to classify
AutoML, and be more searchable,
more easy to access now.
MARK MANDEL: That's very cool.
And I think we're trying to
get them on the podcast, too,
aren't we?
GABI FERRARA: Yes.
They're going to
be on the podcast,
and they're going to be able
to talk more about that.
I'll be interviewing them.
MARK MANDEL: So stay tuned.
Well, why don't we go have a
chat with our friend Mohamed
over at Voicea?
GABI FERRARA: Yeah, let's go.
MARK MANDEL: I am exceptionally
delighted to be joined
by Mohamed El-Geish,
chief architect at Voicea,
coming to chat with us today
on the podcast about everything
they do.
How are you doing
today, Mohamed?
MOHAMED EL-GEISH:
Good, how are you?
MARK MANDEL: Doing pretty well.
Thanks so much for joining
us today, and talking
to us all about Voicea.
MOHAMED EL-GEISH:
Thanks for having me.
GABI FERRARA: So Mohamed,
what do you do at Voicea,
and who are you?
Tell us.
MOHAMED EL-GEISH: Al right, so
my name is Mohamed El-Geish.
I'm a chief architect
and co-founder of Voicea.
I'm responsible for design and
other architecture tasks here.
And I write code, I
do some other tasks
that co-founders do, like
changing the light bulbs
and all that-- so
almost everything
you can imagine-- at a startup.
True story.
[MARK AND GABI LAUGHING]
MARK MANDEL: I feel like that's
a thing co-founders always
have to do.
That's awesome.
So tell us about Voicea.
Like, at a high level,
what does this company do?
MOHAMED EL-GEISH: Yeah, so as
you can imagine from the name,
we're all about voice, and
enterprise specifically.
So if you think, really,
about how we use voice
in our day-to-day,
especially at work,
there are almost
three big categories.
One of them is
actions that you take.
So imagine, for example,
if you have an assistant,
like Alexa or Google Assistant.
And then you talk
to the assistant,
and it executes the actions for
you, like turn on the lights
and so on.
The big category for
us is that workflow
integrations, that
you actually want
to automate a lot of actions.
And enterprise-- you can
imagine you walk to a meeting,
and you're kind of lost.
You don't know
what the agenda is,
what is going to happen
after the meeting is done.
And we want to
automate the process
of listing other outcomes of the
meeting in a very concise way,
and converting
those into actions.
So you can say,
like our assistant
is Eva, what's the stock
price of Google today?
Create a task for
me to follow up
with IT regarding
security policies.
And this becomes an
actual action or task
in your task management
system, like Trello
or your system of choice.
And then the other big
category is information.
So you are in a
meeting, and you want
to capture or query
some information
from another system.
So for example, you can ask
Eva, OK, Eva, show networks
or social media.
MARK MANDEL: I'm
not doing that now.
I promise.
GABI FERRARA: No,
nobody does that.
MOHAMED EL-GEISH: So
focusing on the conversations
and focusing on
the people there.
So that's the biggest
value add, I think.
When you're in a meeting, you're
very focused, you're present,
and you have really
high attention AQ--
so attention quotient, I think.
So that's the word
I was looking for.
And you want to be focused on
the conversation and the people
around you.
And Eva would
basically take care
of taking notes when
you tell the assistant,
this is an important moment,
and this is an action
I want to be following up with.
MARK MANDEL: That
sounds really cool.
You've also got
integrations with a bunch
of different systems.
You mentioned action items,
and actually doing things.
Can you tell us, what
does that actually
look like in my day-to-day?
Am I sending
notifications via email?
Or what are the cool
things I can do?
MOHAMED EL-GEISH: Right.
So a lot of these
systems actually
allow you to send them emails
to create something in them.
You can, for example,
create a card in Trello,
or create a task in
Jira, or a ticket.
And we plug in
into a lot of them.
So you can actually
go to our website
and explore other
systems we plug into.
And we configure it easily
with a single email address.
And Eva will send
anything that you
want capture into these
systems, and basically starting
that workflow, kicking off
that action, which is maybe
creating a note, or creating a
task, and so on and so forth.
If you imagine you have
your notepad and your pen,
and you walk to a meeting,
you can actually talk,
and you can tell Eva
that this is important,
and this is what I
wanted to capture.
Instead of like scribbling, and
maybe losing a few minutes here
and there of that
meeting you could
have spent focusing more
on the people around you
and the conversation, for sure.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So yeah, you're the
chief architect,
and this is the GC podcast.
I want to get into the
technology side of things.
What technologies do you
use to make it a reality?
I'm guessing there's
kind of two parts to it.
I know there's probably
the transcription,
but then there's
also pulling out
the highlights and
the action items,
and actually doing the actions.
So what are the bits and
pieces that you're using here?
MOHAMED EL-GEISH: Right.
So we're really
big on Kubernetes.
It's something I have
very deep appreciation,
coming from a background where
I actually built something
very similar at Microsoft.
It was really hard.
It was very complex.
And we understand
how life, right now,
for startups and
companies that are growing
is much busier than it used
to be like a decade ago.
So you can actually just
walk into your terminal,
and type in a few
commands, and voila, you
have a cluster running
in GCP, which is amazing.
And you don't have to
worry about a lot of things
like provisioning at scale,
and so on and so forth.
So this is one of the
biggest items we have
that we kind of
don't worry about.
So we let Google manage the
Kubernetes installation for us,
and we will worry
about the application,
and growing the business, and
basically the infrastructure is
kind of we're taking care of
in the GKE, which is the Google
Kubernetes Engine.
So our biggest focus
now is just how
to understand the
business, the integrations,
and growing the machine
learning systems we have.
And we don't worry about
the scaling or these things.
Of course we understand
how GKE works,
and we know how to tweak
it to-- our systems
are very complex as well.
But it takes all of
complexity away for sure.
So Compute Engine,
GKE, Stackdriver,
all of these tools, also the
storage systems and whatnot
are really great for
any startup to go to GCP
and start working on
growing their business
and not worrying about
managing services like that.
GABI FERRARA: So with all of
this tooling that you use,
sometimes you face
some challenges
because you have
a learning curve.
You need to learn how
to use Stackdriver.
I need to learn how to use
this or how to use that.
How does this affect the
development and the challenges
that you ended up facing
for your product on Voicea?
MOHAMED EL-GEISH:
That's a good question.
So there are layers
of abstractions
that might isolate you from
the underlying problems
that a lot of
distributive systems face.
So back in the day
when you were building
your own setup,
your own cluster,
you had to worry about where
I'm going to get my machines.
So if I have to buy
or provision hardware,
I have to put it
in a data center,
I actually have to worry
about the correct space,
I have to worry
about networking,
I have to worry about
physical security.
a lot of things.
And then after all
this, you still
have to worry about
the actual systems that
are running the databases
and file storage,
and backing up systems
redundancy, high availability.
And on top of all of
this, your application
has to be up and
running, and available,
and performance, and all
these nice characteristics.
So if you think about
the balance between doing
all of the above versus
learning a framework
or learning something
that's, I think,
relatively simpler, like
how to work with Kubernetes
or how to work
with Stackdriver, I
think we're in a much,
much better place today.
It of course can improve,
meaning that there are actually
some startups and some other
companies whose entire business
model is basically
simplifying this even more.
But I think it's the
right balance for what
I would call understanding
the complexity underneath,
or basically peeling
the layers of the onion.
If you're working on
an operating system,
you need to understand a
little bit of the foundations
of this operating system, how it
schedules tasks, how it manages
files, and so on and so forth.
In the world we
live in, you have
to understand the data center
operating system, which
is in our case Kubernetes,
like how it schedules Docker
containers, and what happens
when some conditions aren't
met, and you might
be in the risk
of losing your data or not.
So there are of
course some constructs
you have to understand.
But for the most
part, I think we're
in a much, much, much
better place than before.
And that allows us to
move faster and focus
on our own application
concerns, versus learning way
deeper things in the stack.
And of course, the thing that
I would emphasize in this
is, the more you know,
the better you are.
Knowledge is power.
And if you understand
Kubernetes very well
and if you understand
how Stackdriver works,
you're going to be able to
perform faster and move faster.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
I'd love to hear more about
the flow of information,
too, in the system.
Because I'm guessing
there's more to it
than just Kubernetes, right?
I'm guessing there's some
audio coming in there,
and doing some
processing, maybe.
And then are you running
custom ML models,
you putting other tools in it?
What's that flow of information?
How is that all
getting processed?
MOHAMED EL-GEISH: Yeah,
it's a great question.
So our basic input is audio.
And there's some metadata
that are associated
with such audio recordings.
So we join the meeting, and
we record what's happening.
We also respond to commands.
And that's technology
in machine learning
known as keyword spotting.
So we run this in a
very real-time fashion,
that you want to respond right
away to the user's commands
and execute them.
So there's a really
good separation
here between what we can
classify as real-time, versus
nearline, versus
offline processing
of audio and other
metadata we consume.
And we depend
heavily on Kubernetes
to actually schedule all
this workload for us.
So the flow of the
data is basically
the audio is being
captured real-time,
and we're responding to
commands using machine learning
algorithms in real-time.
And we do one pass
on the transcript,
and then we capture
the audio in storage,
and then we do another
multi-passes on that.
And we produce the transcript
for the user at the end.
So as you can see, the
biggest focus for us
is actually how to be always
available, capture the audio,
and not drop it.
And also always be performance
with really low latency
to respond to these commands.
So that's when you're having
this experience, which
is fairly unique, you have
a very powerful computer
or personal assistant
on the phone with you
on the conference line.
So we're talking
now on this line,
and we can actually
invite Eva, and Eva
will be capturing this and
responding to my commands.
I'm telling Eva, highlight this,
or this is an important note,
or take an action as an action
item, and so on and so forth.
So all of these have
to be very performant
and have very low latency.
So we understand the
complexities of, like,
how to route audio
and RTP, or if I'm
a protocol on top of
Kubernetes, and we
have certain requirements around
CPU utilization and memory
utilization for these systems
that are processing audio
in real-time, which is very
important to understand--
the constraints of the
system when you're using
one scheduler versus the other.
And we're really
happy with the balance
we have today, in terms of how
to separate these workloads
in different note pools,
and how to schedule them all
to scaling so that
we are not always
over-provisioning the machines.
So our workload varies
according to business hours
in different locations.
So we can actually
kind of get an idea
of when we're going to need
more machines versus we're
going to need fewer machines,
and so on and so forth,
for each system.
So it's a very
challenging problem.
But Kubernetes is helping
us manage that very well.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, that's fun.
What are you building
your ML models in?
MOHAMED EL-GEISH: Oh, so that's
a great question about machine
learning in general,
and the philosophy we're
taking in building systems.
So as a very fresh
or early startup,
when we started a
couple of years ago,
we had this list of principles
about software engineering
in general, and specifically
about AI and machine learning,
in which we set a set
of guiding principles
for basically coming up with
this decision-making framework.
So when you ask somebody
in the team, hey,
what are you going to
use to build this model,
there should be a very easy list
of criteria to make a decision.
So for example, as a company
that's centered around voice,
and the voice of our users is
very important us to protect,
security is always a
top priority for us.
So a lot of these systems
in machine learning
are really good about security.
We're serving them
through Kubernetes.
So the training part
of machine learning
happens, of course, offline.
But if you're serving
something online,
we're protecting the
data, we're making sure
that everything is
secure encrypted,
then you talk about other
frameworks characteristics that
meet the other set of priorities
for us, or guiding principles.
So you talk about
speed of iteration.
And speed of iteration
or velocity of iteration
is extremely important
in machine learning.
Machine learning, by definition,
or the way it's done,
is very iterative.
It's extremely
iterative, meaning
that you start with some idea,
and you build some hypotheses,
and then you say, this
would work on paper.
And you actually go and
deploy it in the wild,
and you get some feedback,
and you say, OK, I'm
going to have to improve this.
And now you collect more data,
and you keep iterating on it.
So there are a lot
of frameworks today,
like TensorFlow and
others, that make
this process extremely easy.
We have also some flexibility
around what framework we use,
thanks to a new
framework called Onyx,
that allows you to build models
using multiple frameworks.
And at the end
you can serve them
using one of them or a single
engine that you choose,
and you can serve from that.
So we have some
flexibility and freedom
that we allow folks on
the team to actually use
multiple frameworks, including
on the cloud if they wish.
But at the end of
the day, we try
to standardize the serving
mechanism so that you always
serve on Kubernetes.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
GABI FERRARA: So
with all this machine
learning that you do
with different models,
how do you see you serving
the enterprise world,
where everyone has
a different demand,
everyone wants a piece of
you in a different way?
How do you see serving
the enterprise world?
MOHAMED EL-GEISH:
Yeah, so there is
this concept of well-posed
machine learning problems
in the sense that, these kind
of problems, when you're trying
to solve them, you
build up something
and you put it out there, and
users have some experiences
with them, and then
to use the data that
come from the users or the
results of their output
as feedback so that
they can learn more.
And this is where
we are, actually.
It's a virtuous
data network effect,
meaning that if you
are using Voicea today,
and let's say
you're in a meeting,
and then Eva transcribes
something or creates
a task for you, and there is a
very jargony word that you use
that Eva did not recognize,
you can go to our interface,
you can fix it there, and
then we will learn from that,
so that the next time
we would actually
make our best to mitigate
that or fix it for you.
And then the more users we
have from the same industry,
we can have a more
explicit effort
to actually prepare
the words that
are pertaining to that
industry or that domain first,
before you actually
use a system,
or as you can see
the data effect,
the more you use it, the
more it learns from you.
And then it becomes
even more accurate.
So that's really a good
place to be at what
are your problem's well-posed.
MARK MANDEL: Ooh,
but what happens
if you have the
same term being used
across different industries
in different ways?
MOHAMED EL-GEISH: Yeah.
That's when, actually,
you have to collect
some metadata about
who's talking,
and it's more personalized.
And then you can
disambiguate between the two.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
MOHAMED EL-GEISH: So they
might sound the same,
but they actually might
be spelled differently.
But because you know
who's talking first,
like I know your
email address, I
know some data
about the speaker,
so it's more
personalized towards you.
MARK MANDEL: So
you basically need
the contextual
information, right?
MOHAMED EL-GEISH: Right.
And we get that because you
actually sign up with us,
we know who you
are, and we kind of
let Eva learn from your
idiosyncracies, basically.
GABI FERRARA: So that's
how you learn accents, too?
Because I have problems
of some assistants,
because when I say some words,
they don't get what I'm saying.
And accent is really
hard, you know?
MOHAMED EL-GEISH: Yeah,
that's part of the solution.
Yeah.
GABI FERRARA: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: That's pretty cool.
So obviously you're doing
a lot of voice stuff.
Is this is just the beginning?
Do you plan on doing more?
Where do you see the voice
interaction experience
kind of going?
MOHAMED EL-GEISH: I
would really love if I
could have demoed our system.
Because we are also introducing
some video elements,
specifically when it's
a presentation or Slides
that you're showing inside
the context of a meeting.
It's actually very
interesting to see
the interaction
between the voice
and the playback of the
slides, and the highlights
of the meeting, the
minutes that we captured.
It's a very rich
experience, and we're also
looking for something
that we can capture--
whether it's audio or video--
to get more context
about the meeting,
and give it to you in a
consumable format that
is easy to integrate
with your workflow.
So today, we actually
also would have
some playback of the slides
or the video you had.
GABI FERRARA: What is the most
interesting voice application
you created at the
Voicea, the most
like challenging and
interesting thing
you did with that technology?
MOHAMED EL-GEISH: I have to
think a little bit about this.
There are a lot of
challenges in building
a startup from scratch--
GABI FERRARA: [LAUGHS]
MOHAMED EL-GEISH:
--and definitely
when it deals with
non-deterministic input
like speech.
So we have a lot of
machine learning domains
that are easier than speech
or perceptual knowledge
acquisition.
So for example,
if you're thinking
of recommendation systems,
which is something
I used to do at my
previous life at LinkedIn,
I think you have more leeway
or you have more freedom
in showing the user
commendations and so on, on,
for example, the news feed.
But when you're dealing with
human perceptual tasks--
like I heard something
and I need to make sure
that this is the
transcript for it,
it's a bit more challenging.
I want to say, for sure, one
of the most challenging ones
is keyword spotting, and
responding to commands.
It's almost a magical moment
when you walk into a meeting,
and then can talk to
the conference line,
and you get stuff done.
That's for sure a very
challenging process
and challenging problem.
Because you need to understand
the intent of what the user is
saying, you need to understand
where this information should
flow, and you need
to convert that data
into an actionable outcome.
The combination of
these problems, I think,
is the most challenging and
most interesting, for sure.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
And what's been the-- on the
customer side, though, what's
been the most interesting
integration you've seen?
MOHAMED EL-GEISH: Oh,
definitely integrations
with task management systems.
Because a lot of people
like to keep track of what
they're doing, and they
think of meetings as a place
where they get work done and a
place where you can coordinate
and discuss ideas.
And then they come out with
some maybe handwritten notes,
or maybe some cryptic
notes that they
captured during the
meeting because they really
want to be engaged.
And they just type a few
words here and there.
But now they can just
get out of the experience
with a very nicely
fleshed-out list of outcomes
that they just input
using the voice.
I think this is actually
where voice shines.
It's the natural way of
communicating with computers.
So anybody who's interested
in Human-Computer Interaction,
or HCI, they can tell you
that, in the beginning,
we had the terminal.
We had just words
and the command line,
and a very dull
way of interfacing,
because that was the
limitation of that era.
And then we advanced
a little bit
through the Graphical
User Interface, or GUI.
And that, also, because we
couldn't do better than that.
If you maybe saw some of
the early systems that
used voice or other natural
UI methods of input,
they weren't that
good back in the day.
So we had to resort to
the mouse or the pointer,
and then some icons and whatnot.
But now, with the richness of
machine learning techniques
and deep learning, and all the
advances we had in the past,
I would say, five
to six years, it
became possible to
actually walk into a room,
and have a $20 device
that talks to you.
And you can do things with
it, which is, in my opinion,
it's just a revolution of the
UI and the way we interact
with computers overall.
GABI FERRARA: Does that mean
it should have been an email?
You probably are answering
that question with Voicea
right now, right?
Because all the meetings,
you'll get all of the stuff--
keywords, what is
important-- you
send to the integration
systems for task management.
So in the end, you
have everything
that you need just by having
your device or Eva helping you.
MOHAMED EL-GEISH: I think it's
actually a very fair point.
In the future, I
wouldn't exclude us
from doing something
similar, to tell you,
maybe you shouldn't
attend this meeting.
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHS]
MOHAMED EL-GEISH:
As a matter of fact,
we are working on a
lot of things that will
help you make that decision.
One of it is that we have,
as humans, intrinsic Fear
Of Missing Out, or FOMO.
But you don't actually have
to sit there for an hour
and listen to the meeting if
you can send Eva on your behalf,
and Eva will come
back reporting to you,
here are the important minutes.
You can just spend one
minute or a couple of minutes
to listen to the important
minutes, or read them.
And we worked on this
really amazing concept
in collaboration, which
is teams and channels.
So let's say I
manage a team, and we
have a meeting with a
client, and they want
to share this meeting with me.
So they can just
create that channel,
and then I have access
to the channel that has
all of this client's meetings.
And then I can coach
them through it,
or I can follow up
with the customers
if I needed to be
in that meeting
and I couldn't make
it, for example,
or I'm double-booked
or triple-booked.
So FOMO is very important.
And we want to satisfy
that itch by giving you,
here's what's really happening
with this series of meetings
in a very succinct way.
Here are the highlights.
And I think you can
get a really high value
from just reading those
or following up on those
instead of attending
all of these meetings.
And I wouldn't be
surprised if we end up
answering the question,
"should this meeting be
an email instead?"
GABI FERRARA: [LAUGHS]
MARK MANDEL: Or is
it going to be like,
"don't have meetings with John.
John tends to waffle."
[LAUGHTER]
No, that sounds great.
If people want to learn
more about Voicea,
where should they go to
learn about this stuff?
MOHAMED EL-GEISH: So
differently www.Voicea.com.
We're also on
LinkedIn, on Twitter.
Google Voicea and
interact with us.
I would love to
hear your feedback.
And sign up today.
It's free, and you get a trial
for our premium solution.
And I hope you enjoy it.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
And if anyone wants to learn
about any of this stuff
you've talked about today--
it sounds like you're working
on some really interesting
problems-- do you have any
resources that you recommend?
MOHAMED EL-GEISH:
Yes, so definitely
feel free to reach out to us.
We can get you a demo.
And if you want to
reach out personally,
I can also add my
contact information here.
And anybody on the team, we have
an About page and Contact Us
page on Voicea.com.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Before we run away, is
there any other things
that we haven't managed to touch
on that you want to make sure
that people know about?
MOHAMED EL-GEISH: I
think, as a parting note,
this is a very exciting era.
And I think folks--
we've heard a lot of
things about AI taking
over the world and AI being
this fourth revolution
after the Industrial
Revolution, how
it's going to change the shape
and form of how we do work.
I want to emphasize
the way we're
doing things and
thinking about AI more
of an augmented intelligence.
So it's not here to
replace your job.
Some jobs, over time,
will evolve and change.
And some of them are
going to disappear.
But I would send the
message to everybody
to say, think of
AI as your friend,
and make sure that you know
more about what's happening,
because it's going to affect
how we do work in the future.
It's accelerated-- definitely on
an accelerated path right now.
GABI FERRARA: Of course.
It's here to improve your
job, not take your job.
MOHAMED EL-GEISH:
But befriend AI.
GABI FERRARA:
Thank you, Mohamed.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
All right, well,
Mohamed, thank you
so much for hanging out
with us today, and chatting
to us all about Voicea.
MOHAMED EL-GEISH:
Thank you so much.
Thanks for having me.
GABI FERRARA: Thank
you, Mohamed El-Geish,
for helping us understand more
about what Voicea is doing,
and all the insights
that you gave on machine
learning on this episode.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
super-cool episode.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
GABI FERRARA: So Mark, the
moment that you're waiting for,
Question of the Week.
What if I'm working a
terminal in Cloud Shell
and I want to move
to another computer?
How can I continue my work?
MARK MANDEL: So that's
a really good question.
And I found this
out the other day.
I was really excited.
So if you haven't used Cloud
Shell, it's kind of awesome.
It's basically an
integrated terminal that's
built into Cloud Console.
It also has a matching
editor and a whole bunch
of other fun things.
So it means that
if you just want
to get something done with
G Cloud or maybe kubectl,
or something like that,
and a bunch of other tools
that come with it as well,
it's just a really handy way
of bringing up a terminal
and getting things done.
What's super cool
about it is, not only
do you get persistent
disk storage
for a certain amount of time
as well, so you can leave stuff
in there.
And if you move from
computer to computer,
as long as you're accessing
that on a regular basis,
it stays there, which
is really great.
What I didn't realize--
and the implications
of which is--
it actually uses a
piece of software
called tmux in the background.
And if you haven't
used that locally,
it's basically a terminal
session management.
It keeps those terminals
alive and persistent.
So what happens is, say
you're working on one computer
and you're like, that was cool.
And then you go to
the office, and you're
working on your workstation,
for example, and you're like,
oh, I wonder if there's still
a running process running,
or I want to check
what's going on.
You open up your terminal,
and Cloud Shell will be like,
oh, hey, I transferred
your processes
over from the old
computer to this one
so you can still
see what's going on.
And it's all the same.
So for example, I was
doing a bunch of cleanup.
I had a slew of App Engine
versions lying around.
And so I'd written a script
to just delete a whole bunch.
It was going to take
about half an hour.
And I had basically started it
at home, and then got on a bus,
and gone to work, got to
work, and then fired up
Cloud Shell on my workstation,
which was my laptop.
And it was like, oh, I
wonder if it's finished yet.
And I popped it up, and I could
see it was still processing.
And I was in a completely
different browser,
on a completely
different computer.
And I was like, that is awesome.
GABI FERRARA: Mind-blowing.
There's this untold joke that
Cloud Shell is the best product
that we don't advertise.
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHS]
I think that's fair.
GABI FERRARA: So there is
a link on the podcast post
with the feature.
So take a look there.
MARK MANDEL:
Absolutely, fantastic.
All right, Gabi.
What are you doing?
What have you been up to?
Are you going anywhere cool?
GABI FERRARA: So I'm going to
the Museum of Natural History.
I've never been there before.
MARK MANDEL: Ooh.
GABI FERRARA: But I'll be giving
a workshop on ML APIs and Cloud
Functions for their
Brown Scholars program,
which it is for--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, very cool.
GABI FERRARA:
--high school girls.
So that's going to
be nice, because it's
going to be Python, and they
know more Python than I do,
probably.
MARK MANDEL: OK, so you'll
teach each other things.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah, probably.
MARK MANDEL: That sounds good.
That sounds great.
Fantastic.
GABI FERRARA: And you, Mark,
what you're going to be doing?
MARK MANDEL: What am
I going to be doing?
I think the thing that's
coming up most in March, Game
Developers Conference.
We will be there--
all of Google will be
there in all its glory.
If you're into
cloud stuff, though,
make sure to check out
all the sponsor sessions
that we're running on Wednesday.
We've basically
blocked out the day.
So if you want to learn about
[INAUDIBLE] or Open Match,
or machine learning, or all
sorts of other cool stuff
that we're applying to
games, definitely swing by.
And then there's Cloud Next that
is coming two weeks after that.
I assume, Gabi, you
will be there as well
at Cloud Next with me.
GABI FERRARA: Yes.
MARK MANDEL:
Excellent, excellent.
So I'll be presenting
there as well.
And I'm sure you'll be there
doing other fun stuff as well.
GABI FERRARA: I hope so.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
And then way later
down the line,
in April, I'll be at the East
Coast Games Conference as well.
So lots of fun things.
GABI FERRARA: Lots of fun
things and travel to do.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, exactly.
I probably won't be
streaming this week,
just because I need
to get on a plane
and go back to
Australia for a bit.
But otherwise, I'm sure I'll
hop on there at some point
again soon.
GABI FERRARA: OK.
I hope you solve your problems.
MARK MANDEL: There are always
more problems to solve.
The never-ending
list of problems.
GABI FERRARA: OK, Mark.
Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: All right, Gabi.
Thank you very much for
joining me this week again.
And thank you everyone
for listening,
and we'll see you all next week.
GABI FERRARA: See you all later.
[MUSIC PLAYING]